my father decided like hey he should be
taken care of we started with a little
house or shelter for the Buddha statue
and became something beautiful just like
this people help out clean the streets
and that's the original purpose of this
to keep this corner clean and drives
away the violence that affects this
community for this long time you know it
touched me in a way we're out like hey
just actually um being supported by the
people my mother
she comes here every day she feels like
a little seed that she's planning is you
just have to keep on you know feeding it
I just heard the other day they heard
they believe this is the holy site now
so I don't know if it brings good
feeling to people and people like to
come and give a little prayer in the
morning or at night time then it's a
beautiful thing one more download the AJ
plus mobile app and join the
conversation
available in your App Store now